wraps oh thank you Gary thank you for
coming back from lunch and uh
how they talk will keep you entertained
for after lunch so I wanted to talk
about some uh some work which I've been
doing for several years and it's still
in flux on uh trying to make sense of
what it means to analyze graphs at
different scales and the title makes
this perhaps not so fortunate in English
pun between off and on because I would
like to talk both about how you look at
a graph and you try to find
representations of that graph at
different skates but at the same time
what it means to look at functions on
the graph and look at them at different
scales and it turns out that at least in
our approach these two questions are
very related to each other and answering
one answers the other one as well
and
um
there hasn't been a lot of talk yet
about multi-scale my background is
actually harmonic analysis and a little
bit in geometric measure Theory where
there is a long tradition in doing
things in a multi-scale fashion to
understand objects which are complicated
and and have different levels of
uncertainty at different scales and this
is very popular also in image processing
think about the analysis of sounds and
of images you analyze both objects by
looking at them at multiple scales and
and if you want to perform tasks such as
denoising or other you know or
estimation also in uh in machine
learning tasks it seems very fruitful to
look at these objects at multiple scales
where these different scales really
should be handled differently or contain
different types of information
and here is a list of examples where
multi-scale analysis has been
fundamental uh whereas in the all sort
of in Signal processing they all
Revolution due to wavelets about 35
years ago now and uh and it's uh
consequences in multi-scale analysis and
multi-scale algorithms in a variety of
disciplines similar things that happen
in geometric measure of theory where
instead of analyzing a function or
signal multiple scales you analyze a
geometric object for example in in the
cases that I'm interested in you analyze
a point Cloud by looking at it at
different scales
and and then there are many
constructions in machine learning where
and of course also in spatial statistics
in the at least in the low dimensional
case where you look at an object and you
compute statistics at multiple scales
and you use all of them to make to
construct an estimator for the object of
Interest
so what I would like to discuss today is
some ways of trying to bring these uh
these ideas for multi-scale analysis to
the realm of graphs which are usually
thought of very often a thought or maybe
traditionally thought as combinatorial
finite objects well the thing is that
many of the graphs that arise nowadays
are very very large and perhaps too
large to handle or either in the sense
in the computational sense or in the
sense that the fine scale information
that is contained in these graphs is
very noisy and so the finest scale is
not necessarily the scale but it's most
informative for any specific test
and so uh I would like you know to talk
about how to reduce in a in a meaningful
way the size of large graphs by
compressing them at multiple scales I
would like to use this sort of notion to
perhaps make new suggestions for how to
compare graphs we're often interested in
comparing different graphs those could
be different realizations of a random
graph it could be a graph that changes
in time and the most classical Notions
of of graph comparisons such as graph or
isomorphins just is not very well suited
for applications where for example the
number of nodes in these graphs changes
all the time and so we I think there is
a need for more robust Notions of
distances between these these three
objects and finally there is always
noise for example in the way we're
sampling the vertices of a social
network or of a graph how we assign
weights to the edges in these networks
and so uh again the final scale in this
graph might not be the most informative
one and we should have a way of somehow
being able to uh involved with knowledge
out or average It Out by in a way which
is consistent with the graph structure
so as I mentioned at the very beginning
We There are going to be two separate
tasks one that are going to be analyzed
together one is the multi-scale analysis
of graphs where we start with the large
graph and we compress it in multiple
scales and a sort of a dual uh aspect uh
this I guess was mentioned at the very
beginning by Misha this morning that
sort of taking a dual point of view when
you look at functions on the graphs can
be a very helpful point of view well you
can look at functions on a graph and ask
well how should I be doing multi-scale
averages of these functions well as how
do you do that by respecting the graph
structure and so we would like to do
that as well and in fact we will be
doing both things at the same time
the most fundamental object that we're
going to use is the random walk on a
weighted graph so this talk is going to
be in the setting of weighted graphs
which are not directed by most of the
things that I'm going to discuss go over
to the director case at least
algorithmically while theoretically they
are still open questions about about uh
about some parts of the construction
that I'm going to discuss so I'm going
to restrict myself to the undirected
weather graph case and so where the
Matrix of vertices we have weights w n
is going to be the number of vertices
and so w is an N by n Matrix which I
will think of as being very large and
also very sparse
and one can Define uh as uh I'm sure
most of you are familiar with this with
a random walk on the graph that's that
Matrix P which is just a matrix which is
also in Bayern MPI describe the
probability of jumping from vertex I to
vertex J we would like that to be
proportional to the weight w i j think
of WJ as a similarity between vertex
side vertex J so you would like the
probability of jumping from I to J to be
proportioned to that and the constant of
proportionality that makes p
raw stochastic Matrix is this inverse
degree Matrix the inverse D is the
degree Matrix whose High I entry is the
degree of vertex I so the sum of the
weights of the edges attached to vertex
High
so some people like to work with the
random walk Matrix p uh some other
people like to make the observation but
this p is uh is typically non-symmetric
even if W is on the other hand it's
conjugate to a symmetric Matrix T simply
by multiplying by square root of the
angle square root of D on the other side
and so pnt share eigenvalues and pretty
much eigenvectors up to multiplication
by D over square root
other people see prefer to talk about
the normalized laplation they're just
one minus t so similar spectrum and
eigenvectors and yet other people about
the heat chronolograph where you keep a
continuous time parameter T and you look
at the fundamental solution of the
continuous time discrete space heat
equation of the graph
and I will be mostly using T I'll bite
uh you know all these objects are
related to each other I'm going to call
Lambda I the eigenvalues of T so we
start from 1 and they decrease and I'm
going to qualify the corresponding
eigenvectors and because T symmetric
these are these are all real
and a very
traditional math that people have been
using to embed a graph into nuclear
space and that has already been
discussed several times this morning in
particular in the inspector clustering
is the map that takes every vertex X of
G to the m-dimensional vector where m is
a parameter that is fixed m equal to too
many in many cases
where you evaluate the first M
eigenvectors of of t or the laplacian at
the point x
and one of the most I guess successful
and applications of this has been to
spectral cluster now this is a comment
uh in that so sometimes we are given a
graph to start with some other times we
construct these graphs and um and this
is actually I started uh getting
interested in graphs where you start
with data which is actually you clean
and take an RD and you define some local
similarity functions between these data
points for example by using a coroner
such as Pekka ocean kernel and then your
graph has vertices given by the data
points and connections which have
similarities given by this W Matrix but
we will not be uh doing this in this
talk we will usually start from the
graph is given to us and so it might not
come at all from a realization of this
construction at above
so again most of us are familiar with
the properties of random work just let
me summarize some of the ones that I'm
going to need in throughout the talk so
I'm I'm often going to think about p2b
txy which represents the quality of
going from X to Y and T steps as a sort
of uh if you take y as a variable you I
think of it as a bump on the graph a
probability bump uh Center attacks and
with a standard deviation quote unquote
T if we were in your cleaning space of
course this would be a standard heat
kernel looking object on a graphic can
be a little bit more complicated I
already said that PMT are similar which
helps with the spectral Theory and also
computationally we should think of pnt
as being very large in sparse
so the first thing that I'm going to do
is use these random walks to introduce a
multi-scale analysis on the graphs and
later on I'm going to use the
multi-scale analysis to Define distances
between graphs and look at the case
where graphs change in time and measure
how much the change in time of these
different scales
so how do we do a compression of these
graphs well I would like to produce a
scale of graphs if the original graph is
G or X I'm going to produce coarser
versions of it which I can call GJ or
xjs and every point of the graph scale J
that I'm going to construct you can be
thought of as a probability distribution
of the original graph localized at some
point and it's going to be a probability
distribution with
diameter of a support about 2 to the J
so this is what the graph of the
vertices of this graph as KJ are going
to be I'm also going to give weights to
edges and weights on this graphics klj
and I'm going to obtain those by looking
at the random walk on the original graph
as scale 2 to the J and I'm going to
compress it and represent it by one step
of the random walk as scale J so skj we
will have a list of vertices Each of
which is a polarity distribution of the
original graph and a rule for taking one
step of the random walk at the scale J
and that one step of the random worker
scale J will correspond to taking two to
Vijay steps of the random walk on the
original graph so the time of the random
walk is going to be the parameter that
is going to control the scales in these
graphs
and then we will also be constructing
basis functions on the graph
associated with this compression scheme
now compressing a graph might sound like
a cool idea and there are many ways of
doing that the question is what does it
mean to have a consistent or faithful
compression of these graphs and so that
the graph skj is really a compressed
representation of the original graph
that preserves some kind of information
so the definition that we gave for this
preservation of information is the
following we say if you start with the
function f on the original graph
and you
diffuse it by 2 to the J plus 1 steps
that's going to be a blurred version of
a function f because t to the J plus 1
is you know diffusing the values of f up
to time t equal uh to the J plus one
well that's going to be a very small
function well you can compute that
smooth function in a different way you
can start with your function f you can
send it up to this graph scale J that's
going to be a much smaller graph you can
diffuse one time at the scale J and go
back
the results of these two operations is
going to be up to a Precision maximum
which is the only parameter in the
Constructor is going to be the same
so the graph skj is really capturing all
the information that there is for random
works as a time scale to the J plus 1 on
the original graph that's our notion of
consistency and what we mean by saying
that our compression is consistent with
the structure of the original graph
and I'm going to go over this more in
detail but that's that's sort of the
idea
so why should this be possible why
should it be possible at all to compress
a graph according to this Criterion well
the idea is that if you look at the
Spectrum of T it starts from one and it
typically decays as a certain rate by
the way I think there are many open
research questions about what this rate
exactly is we understand it very well
when the graph is a geometric graph so
it comes from a point Cloud using
construction similar to the ones that I
mentioned before but in general I think
there is a lot of things there are a lot
of things which are not understood about
the behavior or spectrum of T4 high
frequency eigenvalues
and well so if you look at the Spectrum
of T decays so if you ask well I fix a
certain pressure Precision Epsilon here
I fix the Epsilon kind of large like 0.1
then I don't need the all Spectrum in
order to capture my operator T up to
Precision apps you know I could compute
for example the SVD of t or computer
again very design compactor of of the
operator or T and stop every stage of
the spectrum and I will obtain about
maybe 17 eigenvalues and corresponding
eigenvectors and these eigenvectors span
the range of T up to Precision Epsilon
and then if I apply to the range of T
the operator t squared I'm going to look
at the Spectrum of T Cube well by Decay
is even faster and so there is an even
smaller set of eigenvectors with Spanish
Subspace which effectively up to
Precision Epsilon spans the range of TQ
and so I could keep going obtaining a
chain of included subspaces and what
there is a canonical basic form of a
Subspace is given by the eigenvectors of
T but I don't like those eigenvectors
because they're typically no Loca I
would like to obtain bases for subspaces
like this which are made of local
functions not of eigenvectors and so the
name of the game would be aiming to get
this nasty sequence of subspaces which
gets smaller and smaller and capture
lower lower frequency information for
functions on the graph and and CK
localized set of basis functions for
both subspaces
how do you measure the quality of this
course to me I mean you you said that
you're getting a compression but you
didn't give us anything yet any
quantitative way to say correct so so
I'm gonna go back a second because that
is going to come in but certainly the
more technical part of the talk but it's
a great question and I would like to at
this attempt to answer that right now so
if we did the compression in that way
then if I start with function f and
apply this power of T and then I discard
that part of a spectrum that is small
that corresponds to throwing away
frequencies of F that have gone below my
threshold and so we have two distance
between the left and side and what we're
going to construct on the right hand
side is going to be inner two of the
graphs more of an Epsilon so that's our
Criterion for faithfulness and the the
only guarantee pretty much of the
construction
so this construction is naturally lossy
then it's naturally losing in the sense
that the scale J what we're going to
lose is any information about objects
which do not come by running the random
walk at time to do a j plus one but
maybe you know come from running it at
much smaller time scale so that they
have fine structure that has not been
killed yet by the random walk at that
time scale so think of running the
random work as moving out features of a
function f so if you start with an F
which is very regular on the graph
applying T smoothness is out the more
you run the random walk the smoother the
object that you obtain and so what we're
going to lose as KJ are all the details
that have been killed by running the
random walk for time 2 to the J plus one
no more no less actually exactly that
that amount of detail perfect compared
to just like a low rank approximation to
the original Matrix exactly so these are
exactly lower rank approximations to the
original Matrix there is a natural basis
there the basis of eigenvectors but we
don't want to use the basis of
eigenvectors because the eigenvectors
are typical non-local objects and so if
I were to compress the graph by using
eigenvectors my I wouldn't have a good
interpretation for the nodes of my
compressed graphs each node would be
like an eigenvector and that's a global
object it doesn't preserve any local
information about my original graph
doing eigenvectors would be like doing
free analysis of a signal where you use
sine and cosine functions which are
spread all over space what I would like
to do is analyze My Graph and my
functions on the graph by using
localized functions on the graph so if I
get the large coefficient here I know
that something is happening here and not
elsewhere and so that's sort of the the
idea replacing the basis of eigenvectors
of these subspaces with a better basis
so it would be more like sparse PCA in a
certain sense if
make a comparison with PC
yes
or functions over graphs I will be doing
both right now I like to keep the the
confusion both things will happen at the
same time but you're now reducing the
I will be reducing the vertex act so far
no and I haven't told you yet even what
the vertices of the new graph are going
to be yeah but we will be reducing them
in the same way as these basis functions
will be reduced yes
oh yeah I'm sorry so the x-axis is the
index of the eigenvalues and therefore
the OV eigenvectors of T and the y-axis
are the eigenvalues of t or t Cube or t
to this Sigma from E is the set of
eigenvalues the spectrum and so when I
look here I say well there are 17
eigenvalues of T which are above 0.1 I
could truncate here and at every point
on this axis not only at the index of
eigenvalue but I could think of having
an eigenvector and so I could Define a
space spanned by the eigenvectors V1 to
feed 17 and there will be a Subspace
which is almost the rank of T if I
discard everything which is below my
position 0.1
so these are exactly lowering
approximations but where I would like to
have my basis vectors to be localized on
the graph
so the way we're going to do that is is
the following so we start with v0 that's
a basis made of Delta functions on the
graph so every basis function in v0 is
just zero everywhere and one at a
certain vertex which is this is a nice
super localized uh set of basis
functions for the graph and we're going
to apply to each of these Delta
functions the random walk once so we
apply the Matrix T and where each of
these Delta function is going to take
one step of the random Mark and it's
going to be like a little bump a little
gaussian bump if you want the time equal
to one
and that's what I call V1 tilde and then
we look at if you want tilde and we say
well if we look at the grammar Matrix of
this V1 T does how does that look like
well the chromium Matrix that the phi12
that are simply The Columns of T so we
know exactly what the chromium Matrix is
like
and we know that the Spectrum decays and
so we don't really need all of if you
want tildas to span the range of T we
can throw some of them out and so we use
an algorithm which I will detail later
on which essentially for the view
familiar with the numerical side of
these things uh rank Rebellion QR
factorization to look at these bumps
into one tilde discard the ones that are
not needed to span up to Epsilon the
range of T and keep all the ones that I
need and the orthogonalize them That's
What I Call V1 so we stack over here
throws away something when tildas keeps
the ones that are needed and the locally
orphan normalizes them so if you want
now is an orthonormal basis for the
range of T up to Epsilon so it has
discarded part of the spectrum
so now we have t that goes from our
original Delta function bases to this
new basis for the range it's t again
except that you know the part of the
spectrum of TB low Epsilon has been
thrown away so it's a rectangular Matrix
V1 is as a number of columns which is
smaller than v0 and so I can think of V1
as this new basis as sort of well both a
new set of basis functions on the graph
and a phenomenal set of basic functions
on the graph but can also think of each
of the columns as a new vertex in a
graph
and well which edges should I pick on
this graph well on this graph I could
assign edges with weights given by t
squared
represented on the basis of v1s so t
squared if you want V1 so I use these
indices to say this is the random work T
but represented as a rectangular Matrix
mapping vectors represented with respect
to v0 to vectors represented according
to V1 so for sure I can also consider
the square Matrix t-square V1 V1 it's
just two steps of a random walk as a
linear Operator by represented with
respect to my new smaller basis V1
and so
that's a square Matrix which you can
think of as as being a weight Matrix on
the vertices uh of the graph
given by The Columns of V1 so this is a
smaller graph and we have a random walk
on it which is just this Square just
represented with respect to the new
basis
now when we apply t-square in this new
basis to V1 we get Phi to tinders these
are again bumps on the graph which can
get compressed the ones that are not
neither have thrown away and the
remaining ones are of phenomenalized and
the procedure continues in this fashion
and at any stage the this the diagonal
steps which are these compression steps
and orthogonal is combined with
orthogonalization are such that the new
basis that you get spans up to Epsilon
the same the range of T2 to the J
applied to the previous basis so that
this sort of guarantee about the
subspaces being correct is preserved
and if you think about what we have done
we have used t as a dilation which is
one of the ingredients in the weather
constructions in wavelets you start with
a mother wavelet a sort of template
function you start dilating it
that's what the random walk is doing for
us and then in wavelets you dilate by
factor of two and you throw every other
wavelet out that's a down sampling step
where things get compressed well in our
case the rule is not that simple we're
on a graph so the compression is
happening in this uh in this diagonal
steps where only the necessary functions
to spend the effective range of the
operator are being kept and
orthogonalized to each other
and the features that we can start we
think of them as scaling functions well
like localized bumps on the graph
and there are fewer and fewer as we go
up
so in tutoriality what we've done is
sort of going from A Fine scale up we
start with the large graph with Delta
functions on it and we've constructed
courser and scores or functions and our
graph has scaled J is made as vertices
given by the scaling functions and edges
whose strength is given by this operator
t to the 2 to the J maybe over here
represented on the corresponding basis
I'm going to write it down in the next
slide so the graph is KJ is made as
vertices given by VJ
and there is a random mark on it t sub J
which is nothing but the original random
walk at time scale to the J plus 1
represented in this bases so if VGA has
N Sub J columns then this is a small N
Sub J by N Sub J Matrix
and the guarantee that we had at the
beginning is satisfied in the sense that
if you start with a function f and you
apply the random walk operator to It 2
to the J plus one times
you can obtain that by simply starting
with your function f projecting onto VJ
taking one step on the compressed graph
and then I'm compressing
the L2 distance between the right hand
side and the left hand side is less than
something like J Epsilon and Jane is
goes from one to something like Logan
any questions about this yes the entries
of T sub J guaranteed to be non-negative
no so the entry so these are weird
weights uh TJ in general has both
negative and positive entries and all
our consistencies are measured in L2
that's uh annoying and natural I would
like my VJs to be non-negative and my TJ
to be raw stochastic I think that if you
impose those conditions I mean the
problem is already kind of our disease
and I think that important processary
constraint is quite hard I'll buy it one
of the directions in which we're going
is uh is a different direction where
instead of doing sort of linear algebra
type of thinking here we are doing
um a sort of uh we're thinking instead
of you know random works are presented
as matrices and their powers really
about compressing the stochastic process
itself and we're able to get then tjs
which are actually against stochasticity
processes that turn out to be no Mark of
what say my Markov but then as a
probabilista more I'm happier about that
construction this is a
work currently being done with John
mathematically it's not out of
fabrication yet there's still quite a
bit to do but it's it's a construction
which probabilistically I find much more
satisfying
yes so your chain is reversible right
the chain is reversible yes correct
nothing will change uh for the director
case
turns out that the algorithms that we
use to do the compression and so on work
uh without any trouble in the director
case
okay yeah so um
right and now I'm going to give you an
example of how this computation is being
run so you can think that you can start
with the function f on the original
graph so it can be rough and it has
already tasted the fine scale graph and
we can apply the compressed version of
T28 so now the result of this is a
smaller Vector which is a function of
the smaller graph P1 and it corresponds
to have having been diffused once and
when you can keep diffusing
till scale J
and so you get F multiplied by a chain
of compressed diffusions and now the
result is represented is a very smooth
function but is not being represented on
the whole graph it's represented on a
much smaller graph
which which has the size as the equal to
the number of columns of Vijay plus one
so better representation of the result
of
applying you know this power of T to f
if you don't like the compressed
representation you can unpack it and get
your function back this is sort of inter
so we know that this is a very smooth
function so we can represent it
compactly or we can interpolate it back
without adding or losing any information
back to the original basis and so you
can go back
and sort of re-represent this result
onto VJ onto the previous basis this is
just the change of basis from a Corsair
basis to a finer basis the function is
not changing these are all equalities up
to Epsilon oh and you can go all the way
back till you represent your result on
the original basis so here you add the
result of the computation compressed
and you cannot compress it back
and there is only one point here where
we're using reversibility which is
actually the web explicit expression for
these in terms of T itself if T was not
reversible we will be T transpose is
there but that's that's all actually
all right so once you have done this
compression scheme you can do several
things you can compress you can compute
t to the TF very quickly for all values
of T you can even compute the inverse of
the laplacian or a weighted version
thereof like one minus gamma T inverse
by using uh this product formula that
all involves binary power so gamma team
these objects have all been compressed
and so you can compute that product
which of course is not really infinite
and you should be always be working with
iPhone orthogonal to the kernel orbit
operator you can apply quickly
so let me show you some examples of the
simplest one is of course the circle so
this is a graph where every node is
connected to the nearby nodes and here
are some scaling functions so again the
input of the algorithm is just the
adjacency Matrix of the graph it
construct The Matrix T and it takes C in
a parameter which is the approximation
error Epsilon and many speeds out the
whole multi-resolution analysis so no no
ordering of the points nothing of course
matters to the algorithm except the
Precision parameter Epsilon so it output
several scaling functions several
wavelet-like functions these are going
to cursor scales and this is the courses
scaling function of all if you look at
it it's sort of half of this is sine or
cosine function which is the top
eigenvector but it's actually more
localized than sine it's zero almost
everywhere on half of a circle and then
it's not zero on the other hand and the
second scaling function will be zero
there and one here so it's a it's parts
of MB eigenvectors and steps and clearly
involves our sparser but we still spend
similar subspaces so you could look at
that by doing a sort of spectrum
diagrams every one of these matrices is
the set of inner products between sub
apis or Aviation vectors available
fashion and the index rows so the index
of the rows here is I and the vjkas are
the scanning functions that we construct
as scale J and if you look at how they
look spectrally they look mostly
localizing below frequency bands and
then some of them look like wavelets so
if I look at the row here this is
telling me that these scaling functions
over here are localized and Below
frequency eigenfunctions and then as we
go up in the index of the scaling
functions these are spanning
subspaces which are similar to the
Subspace is spanned by certain groups of
contiguous eigenvectors so this is
really doing a a speckled composition of
a matrix T going from low frequency to
high frequencies and similarly what
happens with the wavelength
and and the plots are going from Finance
Finance scale to cautious scales so the
number of vga's got gets smaller and
smaller initially we have quite a few
and then in the end we only have a
couple of scanning functions and waves
and you can look also the Matrix T being
compressed so the Matrix T initially on
the circle is a tri diagonal as we go up
this case if we kept the Matrix t with
respect to region basically becomes less
and less concentrated around the
diagonal but we're also compressing it
so our T's become Fuller all of these
are in log scale log time scale so
become Fuller but smaller so the
original one was a thousand by a
thousand after a few scale it's a 30 by
30 Matrix and by the end it's a one by
one Matrix
so the way you can think of this also
pictorially is that if you have a graph
where every point is connected to the
nearest points and this can this is a
geometric graph coming for example for
my point cloud in 2D what the algorithm
is doing is creating sort of a set of
multi-scale landmarks on the data those
are the red dots from find to core scale
and it's creating edges and these edges
somehow summarize the strength of the
random walk between the red dots so for
example a single edge over here in the
compressed graph which now has very few
vertices the number of red dots in there
what is that the weight over here is
really the sum of all the probabilities
on on Long Paths of the original random
walk
so you can do this on any manifolds you
just sample from the manifold you
connect every point to the nearest
neighbors and you get the multi-scale
analysis we try to do this so some text
documents so this is a different data
set than the one that Ravi was showing
earlier on this morning it's just a
simple data set of papers from Science
News there are about 5000 papers from
from
we start with the dictionary about 10
000 words and then we pick the words
that appear meaningfully in this set of
text documents and turns out that about
a thousand words are left so
unfortunately this Matrix looks almost
like this if it's square but it's not
every column is a document and every row
is a word and let's just put zero one
whether you know to you know whether the
word appears in the document or not so
you can embed these documents in low
dimensions and color them by topic we
know the topic for this document
somebody write them all and categorize
them but you can also do a multi-scale
analysis on this document corpers and
you get scaling functions which are like
local clusters of documents and you can
look at the corresponding words and so
here are some examples some of the
scaling functions going from finer scale
to courses case being localized on
certain topics and and then you can
simply list The Words which are more
representative of both topics
all right so just a few details uh maybe
two minutes because I want to talk about
dynamic graphs on the compression step
the compressor step is achieved by what
are called rank rebuilding QR
factorizations so those are cure
factorizations so you write a matrix as
the product of Q times R where Q is an
orthogonal Matrix and the RN upper
triangular Matrix and in fact you don't
want to do this for the Matrix the
itself you you should be allowed to
permute The Columns of T the column
ordering has no meaning so you should be
able to permute them and in this rank
revealing factorizations well if you add
a full character composition you would
look in this form but if the spectrum of
T is decaying you can approximate that
product by just looking q11 assuming
that the R22 has small Norm so the the
operator Norm of R22 is more of an
absolute right away and your approximate
your matrix by a partial QR
factorization and now the columns of q11
are what we're going to call our scaling
functions when we compress T so this
will be the scaling function in the
scale one and our one our two is in a
certain sense the operator t represented
in the range with respect to The Columns
of q1
and so this is the the core algorithmic
part remember that we would like our
business functions to be localized in
general it's very hard to achieve sparse
curve factorizations with The Columns of
Q90 localized and so uh that's something
that we've done a lot of work on and
we're still working on uh essentially we
combine existing rank revealing cure
factorizations with multi-scale
compositions of the graph so we
decompose the graphene multi-scape
fashion and then we do this QR
factorizations locally that helps us
computation because we can parallelize
things and it also helps with the
locality of the business vectors and we
soon come out with a new paper where we
do a new combination of these ideas
which is giving us uh great speed UPS
even before paralysis so in the original
paper we use a modified grungement QR
factorization which is sort of the only
one which is really that you can control
a little bit but it also gives you the
right revealing uh part which is really
important to a theoretical guarantees we
replace that by a combination of
multi-scale partitioning on the graph
with the sparse QR algorithm by team
David at the University of Florida which
is a multi-flow Intel sparse QR which is
already amenable to parallelization but
it becomes the more amenable
parallelization thanks to multi-scale
decompositions and so we are achieving
good speed UPS we still don't know
whether the algorithm is going to be
linear in N or rather I'm sure it's not
for all graphs but we would like to
fully understand which crafts are such
that the algorithm scale is linearly in
the number of vertices or matches
I mean
at the beginning you weren't really
talking about graphs you're talking
about linear operators essentially yes
right so what's we take home when you
start with the graph immediately you say
well the only thing I care about is
actually random work on the graph let's
talk about compressing we get the basis
functions and we get these compressed
graphs but in here now you're really
talking about graphs at some point I
mean or at least on the computational
part well so it's all about linear
operators the graphs come in when where
I say the following so my compressed
graph GJ is the set of basis functions
that I got a state J of my algorithm
sure so I I reinterpret these basic
functions at vertices of the new graph
and they give you edges with these
weights such that if you run the random
work on this graph you actually have
this consistency property right but
there's no difference if you have a zero
or if you have an Epsilon somehow right
I mean it's all that the sparsity
pattern somehow or or if you really have
an edge or not that's not it's not
combinatorial
right I mean what what do you mean so
the edges are all inside T and so
we're using them all the time and they
affect the pattern of the compression
scheme of the VJs of everything else the
notion of locality is coming from the
ground yes right but somehow but but I
I'm trying to understand the algorithmic
part they arrived me talking about now
about using the combinatorial structure
of a graph into all cuts and correct so
there it's all looking at T which has
all the edge information and so the cuts
are done in a geometric way think of
multi-scale spectral partitioning and
and the QR step also when you build
these basic functions they're all
constructed by looking at The Columns of
a matrix T therefore we see all the
edges and and vertices and so on so it's
completely determined by the geometry of
the graph it's inside T it's all encoded
in T and every step
has to abide to the to whatever part
pattern these edges are have around one
vertex versus an average
you look at what becomes
J correct
correct exactly so the way you can think
of the connections as KJ is that well
this part of the graph is now being
compressed to a node this part of a
graph has been compressed to a node and
there is only one edge with a funny
weight well what is that well that is
essentially saying there were many edges
going from here to there and let's look
at the probability of taking any path of
that length because those paths at
length about 2 to a j plus one and let's
replace all of them by only one edge of
the correct weight so that taking random
walks according to this weight on this
much smaller graph which now only has
one two three four six vertices is the
same thing as having random walked here
for two to the whatever scale this was
in steps
so it's not really that it corresponds
to a book
what so the matrices are not stochastic
anymore they do correspond to a walk in
this weak L2 sense in the sense but if
you apply this power of the work to a
function that's why I say weak sense and
you compare the results in L2 I would
like to be able to do it one then the
results are closed but two things I've
been uh I've messed up the probabilistic
interpretation yeah L2 and and testing
on functions rather than say doing the
preparation distance between
to your do your red dots correspond to a
origin of vertex no
and the way I plotted them was actually
by saying every vertex in the embedding
had an x and y coordinate well the x
coordinate is a function on the graph I
can project it onto Vijay and I'm going
to get a new coordinate for it for for
my Red Dot in the new x coordinate and
same for the y coordinate but they're
new they're not they there is a
correspondence because we keep certain
Columns of T which means that the red
dots can be interpreted as coming from
the original vertex set and they're all
include including each other but they
prefer to think of them as new vertices
which are local averages of the original
ones except that these averages are L2
averages rather than again true
opportunities
all right so in the three minutes that
they have left
uh
okay well so there's been a lot of work
especially in the last years about
multi-sale constructions on graphs uh I
think the regional construction is due
to a collection and
microviella and where we take wavelets
in 2D we restrict them to a graph which
was a um sort of coming from the
structure of the internet large-scale
structure of the internet in in the U.S
and you receive these wavelets in 2D
then we did the original construction
diffusion of wavelets years ago with uh
with Rafi coiffman and Yale and more
recently there is a construction of a PM
bandergast and collaborators where which
is a truly uh a true graph construction
leaves on the graph is done on the
spectral side of the graph and there is
a graphic construction by iraldi and
Azari which correspond to looking at all
possible subgraphs of a certain size
called gray flats and try to represent
your graph as a linear combination of
those and and even more recent work in
in a PD setting by Usher and
collaborators and and there are many
trade-offs you can ask you know do these
wavelets have the right spectral
localization special localization is
virtually a multi-resolution analysis
other graphs being compressed as you go
and I think none of the algorithms does
that except hours is very fast transfer
on these wavelets and uh and you know is
the graph compression that is being
achieved if it's being achieved at all
sort of consistent in some in some sense
um there is a lot of work to be done uh
director graphs uh doing learning uh and
seeing how they fit with graph models in
this multi-scape setting uh there are
big big algorithmic questions when are
the algorithms linear in time linear
respect to the number of edges for
example in the graph
um there has been work by yulu at
Harvard on a Heisenberg principles on
graphs how localized can you make these
functions why they're both how localized
in space and frequency can you make
these functions and and so on so
wow so
let me let me only tell you one thing
about dynamic graphs Okay so
I we wanted to introduce notional
distances between weighted graphs and
the way we do that I have one slide that
I think communicates with the key ID as
it is
we do the following so if you can
compress random marks then you can think
that you have a large major spin but you
also have its siblings a different
scales so you have a matrix P for every
scale J forget about the indices T and
tile that I don't have to talk about so
you have we have such a composition
photographs at time maybe equal to one
but maybe a Time t equal to two the
graph is changed and you have again a
sequence of matrices well you can
compare the matrices you can compare
them with a finite scale or you compare
these matrices at any of the cursor
scales well of course if you compare
them with a very cautious scale they
contain very little information they
only contain the information at the
largest scale of the graph maybe the
Matrix is two by two it's only capturing
the behavior of a top two singular
values and correspond eigenvalues and
corresponding eigenvectors if you go
back down to the bottom scale it
contains all the information in the
graph but the graphs might have
different number of edges so it's not
clear vertices so it's not clear how to
compare the two matrices and they might
be noisy so you can think of
representing each graph at every time
step as a vector where every inch of the
vector is an operator and then introduce
you know this feature Vector is a
representation of the graph and
introduce a norm on this Vector for
example by comparing the operator for
the graph s scale a Time t s k j with
the corresponding of period or at the
same scale at time t plus one and you
can use this as a notion of distance
that incorporates information for your
different scales if you want to study
course properties of a graph usually
look at this Vector feature Vector at
the course of scales but you can look at
the finer scale and finer locations and
just to give you an example
uh here is a graph at evolves in time we
built our own stochastic rules for
evolving graphs in time and only
starting last year actually large data
sets have come out and so we're very
excited about getting to analyze those
uh I did I said were released by penny
nail and another one is going to be
released next week by Los Alamos
National Lab where they have large
networks of the order hundred thousands
and million of nodes respectively the
change in time so that's Network traffic
on their own Networks anonymized
so we have a stochastic graph changing
in time and this is like a social
network so new vertices get added to the
network very few drop out and whenever
you are you at the vertex to it to a
network it draws an edge and then more
edges to the friends or the friend that
they connected to so these graphs tend
to become denser and denser in time
and you can measure distances between
these graphs as a function of time
that's the x-axis a difference case so
this is the notional distance at the
core scale and a short distance is
defined scale and for example there's a
situation where the distance that core
scale is small and the distance a fine
scale is large well what does that
correspond to what happened there well
this is the graphic time T this is the
graph at time t plus one a new vertex
got added to the graph but his friends
it makes friends with a Vertex here and
the vertex there and but these vertices
were already kind of close so this is a
change which is large for these two
communities a new friend has joined both
of them but it's not a change which is
larger than the Corsair scale so that's
why the distance of the course scale is
small and the distance of a fine scale
is large and there are cases where both
these sensors are large and the course
in fine scale and that's the case where
somebody joined the network but he made
friends with very far away parts of the
network and so that's a change which is
larger tallest case so I'm gonna finish
by putting up a slide of questions we
did simulated Network attacks and so on
and we're we're really looking forward
testing this on real data which we have
been missing for uh for a long one thank
you very much and I'll take any more
questions
natural
way to think about a graphing uh I like
the question I not thought about this
um
I don't know
very interesting yeah I never made a
connection
um there's a reason to think actually
that this is uh it gives like in fact
like a tree-like representation of the
graph where you get it you know
yeah and and I think that if we looked
at the coefficients in this
representation we would be a multi-scale
representation of that field too because
uh because with statistics of the
coefficients would actually uh still
look out
thank you very much